so we're celebrating music's connection
to civil rights so who were your social
musical Inspirations uh Nina Simone and
AR artha Frank oh yeah good so so yeah
and what i is there like you the CRI the
yeah yeah what I found out actually um
whilst I was learning about both of them
because I I sing them a lot I sing their
music a lot is that uh artha was uh
inspired by Nina Simone uh and she ended
up doing a couple of the songs that Nina
Simone had on on her albums young gifted
in Black yeah you know and uh and
obviously Nina was very much in the the
Civil Rights Movement her music was
about that at some point and they sort
of met in the middle and both of those
women are huge Inspirations for me yeah
definitely it's interesting because
nobody thinks about it but one what was
like the first time you heard artha like
I think I I want to say I was maybe 10
years old okay in my mother's car on the
way to school and I think it was chain
of Falls yeah I think mine was around 13
and it was it was respect or chain of FS
one I can't remember which one but I
just there was something different about
her voice is it just like it just sort
of like hits you like in the right in
the Solar like just breaks you yeah and
the tone but nobody really talks about
this but she actually did Cover quite a
bit of music like that was a lot of her
career which nobody really T I feel like
that's maybe what influenced me to do
like covers all the time because I love
it so much and I love she had this
wonderful magical way of making any song
you may have heard that belonged to
someone else sound like it was already
written for her they were just a
stepping St to get to so when I was a
kid I would listen and I was like oh I
love her like well you know she that's a
cover like they did that originally I
was like wait what respect is a cover I
was like that's what I'm saying I never
knew like all those I ended up finding
that out and I was like I didn't oh
didn't it gosh she yeah Special nobody
wanted her to cover the song oh no no
cuz then it was F it it's not yours
anymore
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home